talk to us how do you define success for
yourself tell us a little about I have a
really good answer for this one this one
I've known for a long time to me the
ultimate success is doing what you want
to do every day and having nobody have
any impact on that I wake up at 6 I work
out till 7:00 I shower spending 10 15
minutes with my kids before they go to
school and then I go to my first meeting
at 8:00 or 8:30 and usually breakfast
somewhere outside the office usually
I'll get to the office by 9:00 and then
from 9:00 a.m. so basically meetings
from 8:00 a.m.
side the office to 9:00 9:00 in the
office until usually six or seven just
every minute book no lunch no one minute
the spare no downtime
meaning out there meeting after minkum
you see what's have you been happening
with this right never yeah you know like
it's every second is booked hi how are
you how are things good great this is
what do you lift la la yeah it's crazy
I'm excited to just they say when you
know something observe cuz something's
right like we collab you do something
I'm sure it's just cool to actually like
meet you and like if something comes up
it's like that's so it's a hundred
percent ready to go yeah I'm like a mini
I'm meeting you in my segment I love
that yeah I believe that I've seen some
stuff here now I just like I like I like
where you're coming from I just really
like positivity good
yeah I'm all about it right you can more
in the world if we ready for this we
have new we have way more positivity and
light it's just not loud yeah we don't
know more of it in the world
we need it to be louder that is the
typical day 30% time I'm traveling going
to clients you know only 10% of my life
is probably Gary Vee when I speak or do
appearances or do something like this
90% of it is me being the chief
executive officer of Boehner X which is
the holding company that owns
vaynermedia and pure Wow the women's
publishing site and so that's how I
navigate you know just meaning operating
operating operating meaning meaning
meaning operating operating how low like
what how low can we go while still being
satisfied is attractive to me for me a
purebred entrepreneur she or he loves
the journey mm-hmm not the stuff you
know one of the things I struggle with
in the current state of entrepreneurship
is a lot of people want the vacations
the watches you know even even the
content of this you guys have such an
incredible imagery I think it's
remarkable
who doesn't want fine things in life
yeah but I think that if you're in the
game just for the fine things in life
for the bottles and the models and the
private planes I think you're gonna lose
and it definitely is not my definition
of an entrepreneur and my definition of
an entrepreneur is somebody who can't
live without doing their thing and
trying to create literally suffocated
for me I think that that's what's
amazing about anything which is there's
many different many different
definitions for you
you know go out work your face off win
and reward yourself with something is
exactly right for me the reward is
pouring more of the dollars and energy
into the company not buying stuff for
myself it's one in the same
yeah it's one in the same I don't I
don't judge you know I talk a lot about
like stop posting cash and Lamborghinis
and private jets not because I don't
think one deserves that after they work
hard it's that so many of the people on
Instagram that are posting that are
fronting
I mean they're like literally driving to
a private plane pad taking the photo and
then driving home there they're full of
[ __ ] and so to me I I think it's amazing
if somebody wants to buy an Armani suit
or a $5,000 pair of a belt or a diamond
ring for a hundred thousand I don't but
that doesn't mean that's right or wrong
what I'm doing with that same hundred
thousand instead of a range is up hiring
two more people because I'm trying to
buy the jewelry company not a piece of
jewelry
[Music]